[Musique]
hello salut à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d'Europe Hebdo on est
ici à Bruxelles au Parlement européen
dans cette édition je vous emmène à
Calais frontière nord de l'espace
Schengen depuis des mois cette ville du
Nord patcalais fait la une de
l'actualité et pour cause 2300 migrants
squattent les abords de la ville dans
l'attente d'un passage en Angleterre une
situation humanitaire difficile et un
symbole de l'échec de la politique
migratoire européenne depuis plus de 10
ans mais d'abord l'actualité Jean-Claude
Junker au cœur du cyclone plusieurs
journaux ont révélé une pratique de tax
rolling au Luxembourg des accords
secrets qui permettent aux entreprises
d'échapper à l'impôt alors l'ancien
Premier ministre du Grand Ducher et tout
nouveau président de la Commission
européenne peut-il jouer au repenti
c'est la question de la semaine par
Simon
Barbar il flottait comme un parfum de
malaise la semaine dernière à la
Commission européenne et si le passé
était en train de rattraper son tout
nouveau président Jean-Claude Junker et
oui à peine quelques semaines après son
entrée en fonction est déjà un premier
scandale le lux leak des journalistes
d'investigation du monde entier révèlent
des accords secrets mis en place aux
au profit de centaines de
multinationales comme Apple Ikea ou
Amazon objectif l'évasion fiscale c'est
ce qu'on appelle le Tax rolling à la clé
des milliards d'euros de perdus pour les
étatsmembres où ces entreprises
réalisent leur bénéfices ancien Premier
ministre du Grand Ducher pendant 20 ans
Jean-Claude Junker était quelque peu
embarrassé face à ces révélations la
Commission fera son travail moi je
m'abstiendrai d'intervenir dans ce
dossier l'enquête menée par la
commissaire européenne à la concurrence
margarette westager devra déterminer si
cette pratique de tax rolling équivaut à
une subvention d'État déguisée ce qui
est illégal en attendant Jean-Claude
Junker se cache après avoir annulé une
conférence sur l'Europe il n'a pas
encore répondu aux demandes
d'explication des eurodéputés après tout
que le Luxembourg soit un paradis fiscal
est-ce une nouveauté comment feindre la
surprise pour la coalition des députés
conservateurs libéraux et socialistes
qui l'ont élu alors Jean-Claude Junker
président de la Commission européenne
peut-il être un
repenti Jean-Claude Hunger peut-il être
un repenti pour répondre à cette
question c'est pervanche BZ que je
reçois bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes présidente de la délégation
socialiste française quand vous voyez un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières ces derniers jours sur la
question du Lux leak finalement on
pousse des cris d'orfais mais on ne
découvre rien d'une certaine manière moi
je trouve que cette enquête est
bienvenue on aurait pu la faire plutôt
hein on aurait pu au moment où le Parti
populaire européen choisissait
Jean-Claude Junker comme candidat à la
présidence de la commission imaginez que
les journalistes ou les enquêteurs se
mobilisent pour dire qui était
Jean-Claude Junker Premier ministre du
Luxembourg pendant des années on le
savait hein che investigation qui était
l'émission qui av été diffusé sur France
2 avait d'ors et déjà sorti une partie
ex ceux qui
aujourd'hui disent leur surprise ou
donnent ça comme une information
nouvelle
se raconte à eux-même des histoires et
là où je dis que c'est très bien que ça
vienne au fond au début du mandat de
Monsieur Junker c'est que ça l'oblige ça
le met devant ses responsabilités il est
maintenant président de la Commission
dans un moment où les États-membres
doivent lutter avec détermination contre
la fraude contre l'évasion fiscale et il
est en responsabilité comme président
donc vous y croyez Jean-Claude Junker
repenti vous y croyez en tout cas je
ferai tout pour qu'il le soit hein et je
constate que depuis qu'il n'est plus
Premier ministre du Luxembourg et bien
un grand pas a été fait en faveur de la
la transparence de la transparence avec
ce qu'on appelle l'échange automatique
d'information hein je note par ailleurs
qu'il a désigné le commissaire français
Pierre Moscovici pour s'occuper des
questions de fiscalité la personne
responsable du portefeuille de la
fiscalité c'est Pierre moscovicii
margarette vesteger qu'on voit dans
votre reportage qui est responsable de
la concurrence mène les enquêtes et à
part tir de ces résultats il faudra que
ces deux commissaires travaillent
ensemble pour en tirer les leçons
monsieur Jean-Claude Junker dit qu'il ne
va pas s'en occuper alors il ne doit pas
empêcher que le travail soit fait et il
doit au contraire veiller à ce qu'il
doit fait soit fait et ça c'est sa
responsabilité alors le groupe des
libéraux démocrates et le groupe des
vertes demande une commission d'enquête
parlementaire vous aussi ça fait partie
des initiatives dont on doit débattre
hein mais si on mène une commission
d'enquête il ne faut pas considérer que
nous ne ferions rien en attendant les
résultats de cette commission d'enquête
parce qu'encore une fois indépendamment
de savoir si on a une commission
d'enquête ou pas on sait que ce problème
existe c'est pas mais alors à partir du
moment où il y a une enquête de la
Commission les parlementaires peuvent
aussi faire leur enquête par ailleurs on
a eu des commissions spéciales on a eu
des commissions d'enquête parlementaires
donc là aujourd'hui les Verts et les
libéraux le demandent pourquoi les
socialistes ne le demandent pas nous en
discutons dans quelques instants
j'imagine qu'au moment où vous
diffuserez cette émission La a été prise
vous votre position
personnelleition personnelle tout à fait
favorable et je parle en tant que
présidente de la délégation socialiste
française bien sûr sujet sur et c'est un
sujet sur lequel je pense que les
socialistes français ont des
contributions à apporter parce que c'est
un thème sur lequel nous avons travaillé
depuis longtemps et sur lequel nous
avons des revendications et des demandes
depuis longtemps mais je veux faire un
lien ici avec l'actualité la Commission
européenne vient de rentrer en fonction
elle va présenter son programme de
travail nous devrons être intraitable
sur la façon dont dans ce programme de
travail la question des relations avec
les pays-tiers en matière fiscale la
question de l'harmonisation des bases
fiscales au sein de l'Union européenne
la façon dont l'Union européenne
s'équipe pour lutter contre l'évasion et
la fraude fiscale devient une priorité
véritable oui mais alors je je vais me
faire un petit peu l'avocat du diable
mais ça fait quand même des années qu'on
entend parler de ce serpent de mer de
l'harmonisation fiscale de la lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale est-ce que
c'est pas une fois de plus des des
grandes promesses vous savez il y a que
les promesses qu'on ne fait jamais qu'on
ne peut pas un jour mettre en œuvre et
parfois il y a des combats que vous avez
commencé qui finissent par devenir
réalité dans cette mandature il y a une
promesse qu'on a fait depuis longtemps
qui est de se servir des élections au
Parlement européen pour désigner le
président de la commission et bien il y
en a une autre qu'on fait depuis
longtemps qui est de d'harmoniser par
exemple les basses fiscales de l'impôt
sur les sociétés le Parlement européen a
pris position très nettement en faveur
d'une telle initiative maintenant à nous
de mener la bataille politique pour que
au sein du Conseil euh les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement se mettent d'accord
pour euh aller de l'avant hm hm est-ce
que Jean-Claude huncard n'est pas
fragilisé et un peu décrédibilisé dans
ce combat justement au vu de ce qui ce
qui a été révélé ces derniers jours mais
ça ça dépend de lui maintenant hein
c'est à lui de dépasser ça je veux dire
lui-même ne peut pas on me dit qu'il est
terré mais je me demande pourquoi est-ce
qu'il se terre parce qu'il pouvait pas
imaginer qu'il allait passer 5 ans comme
président de la commission sans qu'un
jour quelqu'un lui rappelle qu'il a été
premier minist qu oui alors je voudrais
revenir sur euh les S qu' a pu recevoir
et des soutiens assez étonnants on
réécoute Pierre moscoviss et Michel
[Musique]
Sapin l'Union européenne est là pour
faire en sorte que la compétition la
concurrence soit équitable pour
permettre que chacun a des chances
égales sur le marché intérieur la lutte
contre l'optimisation fiscale ça doit
être mondial optimisation fiscale c'est
pas un pays c'est pas un groupe de pays
c'est le monde entier parfois des tout
petits pays entouré d'eau avec plein de
palmiers cela aussi il faut y faire très
[Musique]
attention finalement on l'entend bien de
la part de Pierre moscovissi et Michel
Sapin il y a une volonté de dédramatiser
de dire que c'est un problème global les
États-Unis ont signé il y a quelques
temps l'accord FAA qui justement avance
énormément sur ces questions d'évasion
fiscale et d'échange d'information entre
les banques et les États-Unis
où est-ce qu'on en est pourquoi l'Europe
est à la traain parfois il y a des
bonnes initiatives qui viennent des
États-Unis et quand elles sont bonnes je
pense qu'il faut les suivre et moi je
pense que une des des avantages de cet
accord qui a été passé par les
Américains justement c'est de stimuler
les Européens et les obligé à regarder
un petit peu devant encore une fois je
pense que l'accord qui a été trouvé dans
le cadre de l'OCDE pour l'échange
automatique d'information est une étape
absolument fondamentale et on est aussi
dans un dans un moment où les
États-membres ont besoin de récupérer
euh des recettes fiscales hein donc
j'espère que cette situation va les
pousser va les inciter à aller de
l'avant alors justement vous parliez de
récupérer des recettes on entend
beaucoup parler et on attend des
informations d'ici fin décembre sur le
plan de 300 milliards que Jean-Claude
Junker a annoncé en juillet dernier lors
de son accession à la présidence de la
commission qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de ce plan oui alors il faut bien euh
dire à ceux qui nous écoutent ces 300
milliards c'est pas juste comme ça un
chiffre pour faire plaisir hein pour moi
le fait qu'on parle ce plan de 300
milliards c'est en fait qu'on reconnaît
que quelque chose n'allait pas dans la
situation précédente que la situation
précédente a conduit à une
situation
structurelle dans tous les États-membres
de sous-investissement et donc au fond
il faut pas que ces 300 milliards ce soi
pour solde de tout compte il faut à la
fois investir ces 300 milliards et aussi
regarder qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on a été
dans cette situation de
sous-investisement Al par exemple pour
être clair est-ce que vous vous attendez
à ce que les project bonds donc ces
projets en fait cette capacité d'emprunt
qu'on pourrait avoir au sein de l'Union
européenne via la Banque européenne
d'investissement soit relancé mais bien
sûr c'est une des capacités que l'Union
a de d'être d'avoir un effet de levier
pour susciter de l'investissement mais
il y a un lien entre les deux sujets que
nous venons d'aborder qui est majeur
hein c'est que moi je ne voudrais pas
que à travers ce plan de 300 milliards
on favorise le développement deune
croissance de la création de richesse et
que celle-ci échappe à la fiscalité et
donc à la redistribution hein et lorsque
Monsieur Jean-Claude Junker fait par
exemple de l'avancée de l'Europe vers
une économie numérique de
l'investissement dans le digital je le
soutiens mais en échange et je lui ai
dit le jour de son investiture et bien
il faut être exemplaire sur la fiscalité
Apple Google Facebook Amazon parce que
sinon nous n'aurons pas le retour sur
investissement or ça c'est pas possible
merci beaucoup pervanche Brez d'avoir
répondu à nos questions nous on continue
direction Calais depuis des mois cette
ville du Nord de la France est de
nouveau au cœur de l'actualité et pour
cause 2300 migrants il campent tous les
jours dans l'attente de leur passage en
Angleterre c'est aussi la frontière nord
de l'espace Schengen et du coup on a
voulu aller voir sur place comment les
habitants et les forces de l'ordre se
gérrait toute cette situation c'est un
reportage de Samia deschir Mounir souci
monté par Johann
[Musique]
looiseau chaque jour des dizaines de
féries traversent la Manche calis et son
port c'est la dernière frontière avant
l'Angleterre la porte de sortie de
l'espace
la promesse d'une vie meilleure pour des
milliers de migrants bloqu
[Musique]
ici voilà l'endroit où je dors dans
cette
tente comme vous pouvez voir c'est
trempéous av de parce qu'on est
physiquement faible on ne peut pas
résister à ce
climat Ammad a 29 ans avant de quitter
son pays il était avocat mais il a dû
fuir le darrefour région soudanaise en
guerre depuis 2003 où sa vie était
menacée il est vrai qu'on est sur une un
nombre de personnes qui a rarement été
vu sur le sur le territoire en tout cas
depuis ces dernières années et qui
demande une réponse urgente
actuellement l'an dernier calé comptait
environ 300 migrants ils sont
aujourd'hui plus de
2300 comme Amad la plupart fuit une zone
de conflit et sont donc éligible au
droit
d'asile personnellement peu importe où
en Europe si j'ai une occasion je la
saisirai beaucoup se dis prê à aller
n'importe où
mais de préférence en
Grande-Bretagne alors on va passer là à
côté des stations
servic vous allez
vousesser avec un petit peu de chance de
vous montrer comment ces gars essai de
se cacher dans les
camions et c'est pas facile mais on
estime qu'il y en a entre 10 et 50 qui
arrivent à passer chaque
nuit donc vous avez des migrants qui Ess
de se cacher dans le camion mais s ne
savent pas si le camion ira en
Angleterre ou
pas
calé depuis 15 ans symbole de l'échec
des politiques migratoires en 2002 la
fermeure du camp de sangat avait
repoussé les migrants dans les bois une
jungle démantelée elle aussi en
2009 désormais dispersé dans plusieurs
camps ils ne peuvent compter que sur
l'aide des associatifs comme Christian
bénévle l'Auberge des
[Musique]
migrants
BL si concentre aujourd'hui autant de
nat convaincu c'est parce que l'Europe
n'a jamais harmonisé sa politique
d'asile quel est le problème européen
numéro 1 aujourd'hui c'est le problème
du flux migratoire c'est la stratégie
qui n'a pas été écrite c'est le manque
de contact entre pays européens c'est le
manque de
solidarité en attendant que les États
européens coopèrent les associatifs eux
échangent et
s'organisent
ça va est ch
sontne as sont log ils ont une
allocation
mensuelle je suis vraiment choqué et
bouleversé car ces migrants vivent ici à
calis dans des conditions proche de
celle que j'ai vu dans les camp au
Darfour
des camps de réfugiés de l'ONU voire des
tentes de l'armée la solution commence à
être évoqué par certains associatifs
inquiet à l'approche de l'hiver de voir
les migrants dormir
[Musique]
dehors Calet donc frontière nord de
l'espace Schengen symbole de 15 ans
d'échec de politique migratoire de
l'Union européenne pour en parler je
reçois David COB bonjour David vous êtes
député anglais membre du UKIP écossais
pardon excusez-moi soyons précis membre
du parti UKIP de Nigel Farage et Pascal
reen vous êtes chef de mission de l'OIM
l'organisation international pour les
migrations David COB je me tourne vers
vous pour vous c'est l'échec de l'Europe
qu'elle est ou c'est juste l'échec de la
politique migratoire de l'Europe je
demande unle question simple pourquoi il
passe beaucoup de Pai avant il arrive à
la frontière entre France et oui ils
arrivrive pour la plupart par l'Italie
par la frontière grecturque ex et c'est
pas un question de ça c'est c'est
immigration pour pour un travail mais
quand il vient en Angleterre c'est pour
fait beaucoup de de presse de de
problèmes pour les santé c'est problèmes
pour le logement et aussi il prend les
travail des gens en Angleterre et ça
c'est c'est pas bon et aussi il est tiré
par le il dont le logement et aussi
d'argent et la France il pas fait ça
parce qu'il y a un système différent
c'est juste les contriuables qui qui qui
rear pour être clair monsieur COB c'est
qu'effectivement en Angleterre ils sont
pris en charge par la collectivité même
si David Cameron il y a environ un an à
considérablement restreint les aides
auxquelles les migrants ont droit quoi
qu'il en soit je réitère ma question
est-ce que pour vous c'est l'échec de
l'Europe ou c'est juste l'échec d'une
politique migratoire où est-ce que vous
en êtes de de ce point de vue là vous au
parti UKIP est-ce que vous voulez juste
fermer les frontières ou est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord pour dire il nous faut
aussi une politique d'asile globale non
c'est c'est c'est l'asile c'est c'est
c'est pas bien que des gens viennent ici
il y a beaucoup des autres pays il reste
dedans et c'est mailleur que n peut
faire un système comm en Australie que
nous choisir les gens qui c'est bien
pour notre économie mais les
immigration sonans contrôle c'est
impossible et aussi maintenant à calis
ça c'est un réservoir pour les maladies
euh je ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe peut-être Ébola je ne sais pas
c'est c'est pas vraiment c'est pas bien
pour les les citoyens de de Calais et
c'est pas bon pour pour pour Angleterre
les gens viennent en Angleterre ne
connait pas alors soyons soyons clair
monsieur cobern les gens qu'on a à Calen
ne viennent pas des zones où où Ébola je
ne sais pas à
quelle ils viennent du Soudan d'éritrée
d'Afghanistan mais je pense que Monsieur
monsieur est beaucoup plus précis que
moi sur cette question euh vous êtes
vous connaissez bien ce territoire
est-ce que pour vous on a laissé pourrir
la situation quelle est votre lecture en
fait de de ce symbole d'échec que peut
être Calais je dirais pas échec je pense
je pense qu'en fait on est sur sur un
mode complexe au niveau européen et et
c'est traditionnel au niveau européen
euh trouver une harmonisation sur
l'asile euh c'est un un processus qui
est en route depuis maintenant une
dizaine d'années euh on y'y est toujours
pas arrivé on parle beaucoup de de
solidarité inter état on n'y est pas
encore arrivé non plus on a vu entre
autres sur la Méditerranée le fait que
Marine nostrom se termine et qui est
l'opération en fait mise en place en
Italie pour venir en aide en fait au
bateaux Absolum et donc donc on a une
diminution des financements qui sont qui
sont apportés à ce genre d'opération et
on a entre autres au niveau de ces
opérations le fait d'aller plus vers des
opérations de contrôle que des que des
opérations de sauvetage des vies alors
moi je rappelle malgré tout que tous les
migrants qui sont là sont des êtres
humains je pense qu'il est primordial de
leur apporter une assistance à partir du
moment où ils sont là je pense aussi
qu'il est primordial de pouvoir mettre
en place une une coordination au niveau
européen et un vrai dialogue entre entre
les différents états qui sont touchés
par les flux migratoires et je rappelle
aussi que ces flux migratoires sont de
plus en plus important entre autres dû
au conflits au conflit de plus en plus
proche de l'Union européenne par rapport
à ce qui se passait auparavant vu Syrie
notamment il y a beaucou parle de la
Syrie on parle on parle de l'éritrée on
parle du Soudan enfin tout ça sont des
pays qui sont relat tivement proche de
l'Union européenne et alors pour revenir
à ce que disait monsieur monsieur
excusez-moi monsieur cobern euh je pense
effectivement que que la Grande-Bretagne
est ressenti comme étant un eldorado par
pas mal de migrants quelle que soit la
politique d'asile harmonisée ou non
harmonisée euh je pense que il y a
beaucoup de migrants qui à partir de
leur pays d'origine sont poussés à à
quitter ce pays pour différentes raison
hein donc il y a des gens c'est pour des
raisons politiques d'autres c'est pour
des raisons économiques mais le but le
but ultime qu'il passe par la France
qu'il passe par l'Italie qu'il passe par
la Belgique ou d'autres pays c'est très
souvent la Grande-Bretagne qui est
ressenti comme étant comme étant
Eldorado alors justement David cobern
vous êtes ressenti comme étant en
Eldorado il y a aussi quelque chose qui
est lié à la langue la plupart de ces de
ces migrants sont anglophones et on le
voit bien dans le reportage il y en a
beaucoup qui sont anglophones donc il
est logique pour eux d'aller vers un
pays où ils connaissent la langue non
c'est pas logique aller en Égypte et
c'est plus proche pourquoi il vient en
Angleterre évidemment évidemment il
parle anglais mais c'est pas difficile
d' prendre un autre langue je parle
français pour exemple c'est pas imp
c'est pas je suis sûr certain beaucoup
des gens là-bas il il il il apprend
France français quand il est en France
je voudrais revenir sur les besoins
migratoires de l'Angleterre l'année
dernière on avait été faire un reportage
sur les besoins de main d'œuvre
notamment dans l'agriculture anglaise et
on s'est rendu compte que beaucoup
d'Anglais localement ne voulaient pas
faire ce type de travaux et que bah du
coup localement les bah les patrons
avaient besoin de cette main d'œuvre
qu'est-ce que vous avez dire c'est c'est
parce que les les d'argent c'est pas
suffit parce que trop des immigrants ça
c'est fait de pression des des salaires
évidemment pour quelqu'un dans
Grand-Bretagne pour pour payer le Louet
pour payer les les maisons les enfants
tout ça c'est trop cher pour lui il est
pas dans les social mais les gens les
imigrés qui viennent il don le social il
don les logements et tout ça c'est
impossible et aussi pour la santé la
pression sur la santé quand je il y a
une pression globale sur les le santé
anglais c'est gratuit et c'est c'est pas
gratuit c'est payé pour les
contribuables mais si vous avez un les
gens sans limite c'est impossible à
faire les décisions au sujet de le futur
de de service Santé
et alors justement à ce propos nous
avons interrogé la mère de Calais qui
avait une petite réf
dont elle voulait vous faire part je
vudrais qu'on
[Musique]
l'écoute Schengen n'a pas mis de clause
de revoyure ou de point de situation par
rapport aux événements internationau
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faudrait c'est que
il y ait cette révision des accords de
Schengen pour en faire une
stratégie globale européenne où tous les
pays d'Europe seraient dans l'obligation
pour rester dans l'Union européenne
d'adhérer au dispositif de Schengen
[Musique]
2 monsieur Ren c'est ce qui suffirait
que on réforme Schengen et qu'on fasse
entrer mais je suis pas sûr que Monsieur
Coben soit d'accord l'Angleterre dans
l'espace Schengen pour régler ces ces
problématiques très clairement NON je P
je pense que ce serait une réponse trop
trop simple entre guillemets bien sûr
bien sûr qu'il faut probablement réviser
et repenser eng qui cré il a bientemp
maintenant qui a permis je le rappelle
malgré tout une mobilité intrauropéenne
sans précédent par rapport à ce qui se
faisait par le passé ceci dit moi j'ai
envie de de vous donner un chiffre si on
prend le conflit syrien on se rend
compte que les pays voisin de la Syrie
accueille pour l'instant 3 millions de
personnes déplacées de réfugi de
réfugiés syriens dont entre 1 et 2
millions en Turquie je rappelle aussi
qu'au niveau de l'Union européenne on on
est occupé élaborer des plans pour
éventuellement réinstaller 50000 de ces
personnes euh c'est pour vous donner
quelque part euh que finalement les 2300
migrants qu'on a à Cala représentent pas
grand-chosegar à ce qu'on peut trouver
en Turquie je je crois mon message aussi
c'est de dire la solidarité au niveau
régional elle existe déjà au niveau de
la Turquie du du Liban des des pays
voisins de de la Syrie on on je laisse
de côté aussi la question de de la Libye
elle-même qui n'a pas les capacités pour
l'instant de gérer ses flux migratoires
malheureusement et je reste convaincu
que l'Europe doit pouvoir quelque part
travailler sur le développement des
capacités de ce qu'on appelle les pays
de transit je reste convaincu que
l'Europe doit aller plus loin dans la
solidarité avec les pays de zone de
conflit je reste aussi convaincu qu'il
faut sauver des vies ici et maintenant
ça a été dit je pense que la question de
la santé la santé individuelle des
migrants est primordiale les questions
de santé publique sont aussi primordial
alors le fait de voir est-ce qu'il faut
mettre en place des des centres
d'accueil euh sur sur calis tel qu'on
l'a fait au niveau de sangat je pense
qu'à partir du moment où les migrants
sont là il faut s'en occuper via les les
associations via des relais
éventuellement via via un centre est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec Monsieur
cobern quand il dit que effectivement il
y a aussi une forme de dumping social
quand on a énormément de migrants comme
ça qui qui peuvent arriver alors c'est
c'est c'est c'est son point de vue hein
en Angleterre V Maité des gens sont les
jeunes hommes c'est pas des femmes des
enfants je F des enfants à Cal Mons
oui est-ce que sur cette
question il y a quelque chose à répondre
en fait oui ben je je confirme
effectivement qu'il y a quand quand
quand on parle de l'Eldorado au niveau
des migrants puisque puisqu'on a un
mélange ici dans la discussion sur sur
sur la question du droit d'asile et
l'harmonisation du droit d'asile et puis
puis quelque part la question de de la
migration
économique et sociale oui on on peut
répondre qu'effectivement la la pression
migratoire est probablement trop grande
vers vers l'Angleterre ça c'est un fait
que la solidarité est nécessaire et je
reviens sur un sur un point primordial
je je pense qu'il faut qu'on aille plus
loin sur la coopération intraeuropéenne
au niveau des différents pays et et en
ce compris les financements qui doivent
pouvoir impliquer tous les États qui
sont touchés par la question migratoire
donc je ne dis pas qu'il faut ouvrir les
frontières je dis qu'il faut continuer à
gérer au mieux et ensemble h bon David
COB donc vous vous dites qu'il faut
fermer les frontières complètement pas
complètement mais nous avons un système
comme Australie chois les gens bien
éduqu qui biencomie mais pasmigration
sans limite pour nous la meilleure chose
pour couper nid
gordien alors ça oui effectivement de
toute façon c'est c'est la manière dont
vous présentez les choses c'est que de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive l'idée
pour lesukip c'est de quitter l'Europe
parce que c'est pas ch impossible
système et 28 nations en Europe c'est
pas possible arranger chose je suis ici
j je connais quce qui se passe ser on
sera amené David COB on a en reparlé
largement messieurs merci beaucoup
d'avoir pu débattre avec nous de cette
question nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à Bruxelles bonne suite de
programme sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]
Ciao